you blocked me before no I would I have
not I would have been very sad my
relationship with my mom is very good I
do share stuff with you and you're just
fun to be around I know when it comes to
secrets when I was younger and I would
keep things to myself but now that I'm
older I'm just over her relationship
with her boyfriend and fiance he's open
to me my friend
yeah Ochs Anson I don't have any closet
secrets or anything secretly dating some
of them I would have fun telling new
story about that I have a Facebook I
have a Facebook will you make it enough
week we are not friends on Facebook I'm
a stalker
I stalk everyone I want to give her
privacy also just so many friends I know
I'm not a big personal sharer of things
on Facebook I don't know what you could
have learned from Facebook that you
wouldn't already know from me texting
you but it's not like I had anything
suggested it's just kind of weird to
cross lines when it comes to social
media can I go through your Facebook and
look at him I don't know it's fine no
thought I've never had anybody do this
before this will be interesting
oh well that would not work out in my
favor I'll get over mmm she's very
artistic and she loves photography and
she loves fashion yeah Trump has a
friend I know oh it's gonna say hmm I'm
friends with my fiancé's mom and dad and
all my other's friends mom's so you're
waiting for me to miss you uh-huh
there's okay are you waving at them I
can do whatever I want
well what is she doing she's holding a
beer in her tips how do you do that
these are all expected traveling you
know visiting but seems like she never
post some family pictures this is quite
normal I mean he's having a great time
and he's got fabulous friends why not
take pictures of us and pose it here I
want her to let everybody know that
she's proud of her mother
[Music]
I'm gonna put a selfie of me on your
phone this could take months cuz it's
got to be perfect you know that ready
one two three
do you like it what my hello there are
you talking to yourself
always mmm is the how useful yeh at last
she's posting up fix p IX who's that I
have King Sue's phone don't I look
wonderful laugh out loud and so then you
can apply filter on the bottom why do
you need to filter me you'll thank me do
you want to be friends on Facebook if
she wants me Maur friends I think that
there's a very similar thing that people
do in life that they're now doing on
Facebook which is kind of like
internalizing what your parents do that
embarrasses you having a mother the way
I do who is outgoing and says her mind
just ask her like have the conversation
I prefer it if you stop stalking my
friends I've come to a point where I'm
older now I don't really have secrets to
keep to myself you don't have time for
that to mix this clean it's all good I
mean she's not coming out every Friday
night about Hollywood with me no that'd
be boring much could you imagine you're
spending every Friday night with him Oh